they are the injuries of war you can't
see the trauma the damage from the front
lines this clinic on the outskirts of
cave tries to help
the patients have ptsd post-traumatic
stress
or significant brain injuries christina
vosnitsuna is the clinic's director
our patients are people who lived
through the events of the war our
workers focused on psychological trauma
that they suffered and we work with them
to give them strength to go back to the
front line
al jazeera first met andre at the
beginning of the war a former soviet
soldier he signed up as a volunteer for
the ukrainians just days before the
fighting started but on the outskirts of
mario paul he came under fire something
he can't leave behind it's not easy to
get
away from what's going in your in your
in your head actually it's a pain and
then some
kind of
you know
flashbacks flashbacks you know when you
just
close your eyes and everything just
start to going
faster and faster and faster in your
head and sometimes it's very bad
he struggles with his memory he gets
anxious when he hears the missile sirens
but still
he thinks he's lucky i was lucky because
i
i'm still alive and i have to to
two hands and two legs and i can walk
and
i can remember something that is very
very good
because
a lot of our guys
actually they they died for
for ukraine for freedom for for
everything
they used various techniques here to
help recovery the physical and the
artistic they even have pet therapy the
horses are a popular diversion
it's hard to help while they're actively
serving with the military we have to
stabilize them and get them back to the
front the real work will start when the
war ends
the average stay for patients here is
around three or four weeks but the
recovery
that takes a lifetime
alan fisher al jazeera on the outskirts
of kiev